considera la siguiente curva de densidad
que es esta aunque tiene una forma poco
usual es más triangular de lo que
estamos acostumbrados con las curvas de
densidad pero sigue siendo válida cuáles
de los siguientes enunciados son
verdaderos elige todas las opciones que
apliquen la media de la curva de
densidad es menor que la mediana pausa
en el vídeo y traten de ver si esto es
verdadero bueno nosotros no sabemos
exactamente dónde se encuentran la
mediana y la media solo con ver esta
gráfica pero recuerden que la mediana va
a ser aquel valor para el cual el área a
la derecha y a la izquierda de ese valor
serán iguales así que yo creo que en
este caso la mediana va a estar más o
menos aquí
así que esta es mi aproximación donde yo
creo que se encuentra la mediana y
debido a que nuestra distribución se
extiende más allá hacia la izquierda es
válido decir que esta curva de densidad
es asimétrica a la izquierda asimétrica
la izquierda y en general cuando tenemos
una curva de densidad que es asimétrica
a la izquierda la media va a encontrarse
hacia la izquierda de la mediana así que
como es asimétrica a la izquierda quizá
la media se encuentra más o menos aquí
otra forma de pensar en la media es que
la media va a ser el punto de balance si
colocamos un fulcro aquí
toda mi curva se va a balancear si
consideráramos a esta curva como una
masa y podrían preguntarse bueno porque
no ocurre esto en la mediana recuerden
que cuando balanceamos algo el peso más
ligero que se encuentre más alejado del
fulcro va a compensar a un peso más
grande que se encuentre más cercano al
fulcro así que en esta primera opción
que nos dice la media de la curva de
densidad es menor que la mediana o
también podríamos decir que está a la
izquierda de la mediana si en este caso
este enunciado es verdadero ahora que
hay de esta opción que dice la mediana
de la curva de densidad es 3
bueno aquí indicamos en donde
aproximadamente se encuentra la mediana
para que el área de este lado sea igual
al área de este otro lado y quizás
podría equivocarme en esto pero les
puedo asegurar que la mediana no se
encuentra aquí
el área que se encuentra aquí es
definitivamente más pequeña que el área
que se encuentra aquí así que podemos
descartar esta opción y nos queda el
área bajo la curva de densidad es igual
a 1 pausa en el vídeo y pregúntense si
esto es verdadero y en efecto esto es
verdadero el área bajo la curva de
cualquier curva de densidad siempre va a
ser igual a 1 ya que estamos
considerando el área total bajo la curva
y siempre va a ser igual a 1 ya
respondimos a esta pregunta pero les voy
a dejar una pregunta extra la cual
pueden responder usando la información
que ya nos dieron aquí cuál será la
altura de este punto de aquí en la curva
de densidad a que será igual esta altura
de aquí pausa en el vídeo y traten de
resolverlo por su cuenta y les voy a dar
una pista es esta opción de aquí el área
bajo la curva de densidad es igual a 1
vamos a resolverlo juntos
si yo a esta altura la llamara h sabemos
cómo encontrar el área de un triángulo
el área de un triángulo es igual a un
medio por la base por la altura sabemos
que el área es igual a 1 porque es una
curva de densidad así que uno es igual a
un medio por la base
cuál es la longitud de la base vamos de
1 a 6 así que la longitud de esta base
es 5 así que tenemos 1 igual a un medio
por 5 por la altura o podemos decir que
uno es igual a 5 medios por la altura y
si multiplicamos ambos lados por dos
quintos esto por dos quintos nos va a
quedar
este se cancela con este este con este h
es igual a dos quintos si tienen una
curva de densidad con una forma sencilla
como ésta podemos encontrar la altura
aun cuando ésta no sea especificada
directamente